[MUSIC]
It's a great honor to be here today for
this panel on deriving value
from big data and analytics.
I came to this topic when I started
working for Microsoft, consulting for
their online services division
in the middle of 2007.
And Microsoft entered Online Services with
some amazing talent in machine learning,
but much of the engineering organization
came from packaged software.
And so, I was able to watch and
observe a large company with very
talented people, try to navigate
the transformation into the amazing
world of big data with all of its power.
But so many pitfalls in terms of both
the science and the business management.
About four years ago,
Microsoft brought in an executive, Qi Lu.
For those of you who don't know Qi,
or know his story,
it's really an amazing one.
He came out of poverty in a small
village in China to get his PhD in
the United States, and now he's one of
the top four executives of Microsoft.
And he's a truly inspiring
figure to work for.
He's a brilliant, brilliant scientist
with statistics in his DNA and
I think that's an example of the kind
of leader that we're going to
start to see in the executive
suites of major companies.
Which really looks quite different than
the background and expertise of the past.
So today, our panel has
representatives from three of
the big waves of big data,
if you like, from search,
sort of really the pioneer and
the sort of extreme example of big data.
We have Li Fan who's the Vice President
and Deputy General Manager of Baidu,
and she spent many years
at Google as well.
And she also represents one of
the disciplines of big data that she
spent several years working
in systems infrastructure.
We also have one of
the second waves of big data.
We have Simon Zhang from LinkedIn,
where he's the Director of Analytics,
supporting multiple functions in LinkedIn,
the social wave.
And then we have Michael Lee who's
a data scientist at Foursquare.
He has a PhD from Princeton and
is responsible for
the machine learning that
goes on at Foursquare.
So we have the three waves and
all the disciplines represented here,
so we'll sort of get a 360 degree
view of big data analytics.
I'm looking forward to
a great panel discussion.
So I'm wondering as the first wave, Li,
would you be willing to kick things off?
>> Sure, so first of all,
it's my pleasure to be here and
I'm very glad to see this large audience
interested in China and the Internet.
I view myself as an Internet veteran,
worked for Google a long time,
then Baidu as executive.
Today's topic, definitely a popular one
both in US and China, is the big data.
As we all know, search engine is really
the pioneer in terms of big data.
Baidu as the Chinese big search engine,
index
hundreds of billions web pages,
both in Chinese and other languages.
So for us,
it's really big data is not a new problem.
It's a problem we always solving,
but in my view,
the wave of big data is
really just starting.
Even though people have been
talking about technology for years,
and I think we only scratched the surface.
The reason I say that is at one side,
although we saw like 90% of data right now
on the Internet they generated in the past
3 years, but I see a lot of still coming.
Right now, majority of the company focus
on data on the Internet, be it web pages,
be it communication, their posts, UGC, but
what I see is a lot of more valuable
data to human being is offline.
In the sector of health,
education, merchandise,
there's still a lot of
valuable data offline that yet
to be indexed, crawled,
accessible for user.
And the more I get into this space,
I feel excited because we have yet
to come just in terms of data acquisition.
And on the other side, I think the value
of the data hadn't been really
be seen outside of business world.
When we talk about the value of big data,
a lot of value we talked about is to
really enhance the business value.
Make it a better advertisement,
make a better recommendation,
get more user attraction.
This is really helping the business.
And in my view of years of working for
Google and Baidu,
both companies really trying
to help user as a main focus.
Of course,
we also grow up successful business.
We really hope that information,
not just information,
also the application service can be easily
accessible by everyone in the world.
And by doing that,
data is the first thing.
Not just like when we do data mining,
we do the data analysis and
that's just helping the business itself,
we weren't helping the user.
For example, can we provide a user
a clear view with their personal health,
whether their preferred
doctor is available,
whether the traffic on Beijing,
any road you can be.
It's easier for you to go to the airport,
like those routine things.
I think we have the basic technology,
but unfortunately all the pieces
haven't get together to help them,
so that's my first thought.
>> Thanks, so
now let's go into the second wave.
Simon, do you want to-
>> Sure, thank you, Susan.
So, my name's Simon Zhang.
I lead a current LinkedIn
business analyst team.
So we have about 16 analysts,
data scientists, engineers, in our group.
We support all of the LinkedIn
monetization revenue lines across three
lines of revenue.
And, yeah, cannot agree more with what
Li just shared, and I personal believe.
Recently a lot of buzzword about big data.
Big data sounds cool, sounds hot,
and sounds fancy, right?
Actually, in my personal believing,
I think about a big, what big mean?
Big sometimes means slow,
big sometimes means complex.
Big sometimes means not
many people can move it.
So, actually my job, my team's job at
LinkedIn is how to convert this in
a petabyte, gigabyte, terabyte data
into very small, couple kilobytes data.
To empower a lot of internal employees to
make a quick and valuable decisions and
then drive value because I
like what Li has shared.
So my team cover all the monetization for
new lines,
which sounds very traditional
with her opponent view,
and how to make the insights that
are valuable for a lot of people.
That's my team's mission and like what
you think about, hey, driving value
from the data, right, driving value I see
that every day happening on LinkedIn.
The reason is, so let's take a very quick
look about LinkedIn's business model.
And LinkedIn's business model actually,
currently,
we have 238 million unique
users use LinkedIn, and
every month we have 148 million
users based on ComScore's data.
So, think about this in a hyper growth and
engagement,
actually that create a massive amount of
information, or data on the back end.
The LinkedIn Core business actually we
derived the next wave of the product,
service, solutions from
this massive amount of data
to serve our member enterprise
customers or individual customers more.
So think about it this way
data is a very strategic
component of our LinkedIn visitors.
And then we derive the three remedies,
that we call talent solutions, for some
recording, hiring, jobs, and the second
that we call the marketing solutions.
Folk on advertisements and marketers
serve, we call them premium subscriptions,
targeting unique LinkedIn numbers,
like someone like you.
How to make all of us be more
productive and successful?
So to do that,
a lot of people think LinkedIn now come,
we have a lot of recommendations, right?
For example, people you may know
marginally, the news you may like,
people you'd like to hire.
Higher on the backend, actually,
LinkedIn use data massively to
empower internal teams,
including sales, marketing,
engineering, product operations,
and different departments.
So our goal internally is we want to have
every single employee internally use
data insight to help them drive decisions
every day and then take actions.
So drive decision and take action,
one thing is very important, speed, speed.
So like in the Warhol there is a very
Asian article called the Art of War,
in China.
He highlighted one thing,
speed really matters, right?
In Chinese it's called [FOREIGN].
What we found in LinkedIn is
that when we make the data use
extremely fast a lot of
people would love and use it.
And then we see hyper, hyper growth and
incremental value from there.
So that's why it's a very challenging
topic for professionals like us,
how to make this massive amount of data or
insight into extremely fast insight for
value, and then provide for our users.
It doesn't matter to our internal
employees or external numbers.
And then help them make
decision to make life better,
I think that's my basic
understanding about big data.
Thank you.
>> So, Micheal, now we're onto the third
wave, of course, both search and social
networks, like Facebook and LinkedIn have
a very important mobile component already,
but FourSquare is really lives and
breathes it.
So can you share with us your insights
about big data and the local mobile space?
>> Absolutely Susan.
And I feel like I am kind of
a David amongst Goliaths here.
FourSquare is obviously a much smaller
company than Baidu or LinkedIn.
Just sort of show of hands, how many
people here have heard of Foursquare and
know what it's about?
Okay, good.
I mean, we're at a tech conference,
I would hope that's not zero.
So Susan said I'm a PhD,
data scientist at Foursquare,
and I thought I would
bring in some tools to show you a little
bit about the big data we're doing.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with Foursquare,
I like to really think about Foursquare
in terms of pre-digital analogues of what
you would have done before
you had Foursquare.
So when you have Foursquare, it's a mobile
app, you go to different restaurants or
different venues and
you check in, which is a way of
telling us about that you're there.
So for instance, when I arrived today,
I said hey,
I'm at the Stanford Alumni Center.
I checked in.
They can check in to parks or
restaurants or
even something as mundane
as a post office.
By the way, post offices are the single
most reviled category on Foursquare.
Users hate them.
It's in a very tight
competition with DMVs, so.
>> [LAUGH]
>> People don't like those either.
And the reason we know all this
about these venues is because
when users check in they
don't just say that I'm here,
they tell us about this
is what I was doing here.
This is whether I like it or I dislike it.
They leave tips about food that
you can get at those restaurants.
And from all that data we can
do the other half of FourSquare,
which is recommendations.
So this is a copy of the original
1929 Michelin Guide.
You can think of Foursquare as
the iPhone 5S version of this.
So we do social recommendations.
Your friend, maybe Susan here,
is an expert at French restaurants.
And so if I come to the Bay Area and
I'm looking for a French restaurant,
I would say, hey, where has Susan been?
So you can figure out what way you want to
go based on what your friends are doing.
But we also do recommendations in the same
way that Netflix does recommendations for
movies.
We do recommendations for restaurants and
bars, and different places to go.
So we have 35 million users worldwide.
And what that looks like is this.
I don't know if you can
see it with the lights.
>> That's okay.
>> So this is,
it looks like a map of the world, but
there's actually no geographic data there.
I didn't put in a map at all.
All it is is a black canvas and
there's a white dot,
a light, every time somebody's checked in.
This is over just like six months or
something, and so you can actually see,
you can see the US, Europe, Latin America.
You can see the whole world
light up in this way.
And so this is sort of the macro picture,
this is the big picture of
what our data looks like.
Here's the small picture.
For those of you from the East Coast,
you'll probably recognize
this as New York.
You can see the island
Manhattan down the middle.
If I have a laser pointer,
Island of Manhattan down the middle.
You have JFK, La Guardia, you can see
the actual runways and the terminals.
You can see the streets,
the bridges, this is the ferry going
between Staten Island and Manhattan.
And these are people
checking in along the route.
Again, no map data, all it is,
is just a point for every check in.
And this is my favorite visualization.
This is a time lapsed
picture of what you just saw.
So up in the upper left, that's the time.
5 AM Manhattan's dead.
At 7 AM,
people are streaming into the city.
They're checking into Grand Central and
Penn Station.
Around 11 o'clock people are very,
the city's just throbbing.
It's really busy.
Now we're getting to 4, 5.
People are starting to go to dinner, so
we're starting to see
a lot of food light up.
And then now it's 8 or 9.
People are going to party.
These are the bars.
This is where the bars are.
Williamsburg, lower east side.
1 AM, 2 AM,
people are finally getting home by 3.
The city dies and
the thing starts all over again at 5.
So we have these amazing
views of the city, and
this is just sort of the tip of
the iceberg for what you can do.
I think one of the most amazing things
is after Hurricane Sandy you could see
people would come in the day before and
check ins at whole foods and other grocery
stores just spiked up, as people were
hoarding and preparing for the hurricane.
And then when the hurricane came
you just saw this dip in check ins,
because everyone was staying home.
And then within a few days you saw
the city would come back to life.
And the normal cycle and
rhythm of New York that you just saw in
that animated up there, started up again.
And I think just sort of seeing that
was for me a very inspiring thing.
To see my own city start to recover
from a major natural disaster.
But there's so much more that
we can offer to the world, and
to advertisers, and to users.
>> Wonderful.
So, I think we've really kind of covered a
lot of the different aspects of big data,
so let's take a few minutes now and
dig into them more deeply.
So one thing that Lee raised was
bringing a lot more specific domain data
online and now we have just heard
from Michael about how we can
watch people move at a very fine
grain of both location and time.
I am wondering what the panel
things about sort of new or
maybe unexpected or unintended
applications of all of this information.
We're seeing, for example cities put a lot
of their data online and you can know
about noise at different times of day,
you can know how transportation is moving.
Some of the sources of data
are the mobile phones and
can see how people are moving around.
What does this unlock?
>> A lot of things.
So one of my favourites examples of
kind of data we have at Foursquare and
how we use it in an interesting way you
might not realize that you could do.
So if you think about what we have,
we've foot tracks of data, right?
We've 35 million users walking around
the world telling us where they go, and
the question we want to answer was
finding an authentic ethnic restaurant.
And so you might think like,
okay foot traffic data,
ethnic restaurants nothing in common,
right?
Because what we are really trying to
say if you are trying to find a Chinese
restaurant, how can you tell the Panda
Express of the world from that hole in
the wall place that you just love and
everyone speaks Chinese and
the menus in Chinese and it's just great.
How can you tell these things apart?
It turns out that if you look at
people who go to China a lot and
you look at what restaurants they eat at,
what Chinese restaurants they eat at
when they're in the US, that's actually
a really good indicator of whether or
not it's a authentic Chinese restaurant.
And so, when we did this calculation,
we found out that we picked
things that kind of expressed or
showed up at the bottom.
And the thing that actually showed up at
the top for New York was the restaurant
that my mother and I had actually
just gone to two weeks earlier.
And we only found out about this because a
friend of hers who lives in Chinatown and
only speaks Cantonese told us about it.
So, think about it.
Before Foursquare, the way you found out
about these local restaurants is you would
have to be a local, you know a local and
speak a foreign language.
And now we can sort of just run
a MapReduce and figure this all out.
I like to tell this story because,
I think,
perhaps, many people in this room, I'm
like very proud of my ethnic heritage and
my ability to sort of find
a great Chinese restaurants.
You don't have to be Chinese, right,
you just have to run MapReduce.
To add insult to injury, the person
who did this analysis wasn't me.
It was actually a Frenchman.
So, literally a Frenchman found
the best Chinese restaurant in New York
running a MapReduce and if that's not like
a testament to the power of big data,
I don't know what is
>> So I can see
how Foursquare benefits from those ideas
and of course you guys are most likely to
think first of the ideas that you
can directly put in your product.
Do you have any good examples
outside of what Foursquare might do?
>> Well using our data, or-
>> Yeah using data like this.
>> Yeah.
One of the things that I'm working on is
collaborating with different academics,
using our data for
sort of, social purpose kind of research.
We have a few people that are in the works
that maybe I shouldn't talk about.
But one of them is actually a group
of economists and they're very
interested in looking at tipping behavior
and virality behavior in our data.
There's a lot of study of
virality behavior online.
But they want to know, can we observe
If people go to a venue, is there some
critical point above which suddenly more
people today begets more people tomorrow?
What's in the viral behavior like if
I'm there and my friends are there,
does that make it more likely for
people to come to this venue.
And obviously that's interesting for
us but interesting for society in general.
>> So let me say a word about that
since this is something that I've
been a huge beneficiary of, as well.
When firms are sitting on these mountains
of data, especially smaller firms that
are just growing or
firms that have just entered a business.
It can really be overwhelming to
try to figure out what are useful
directions to pursue and
what directions aren't.
And a lot of the initial explorations
of data can really be thought of like
they're sort of basic science R&D in
the sense that you don't know whether
you're going to get something out
of those investigations or not.
It can be risky for the employees, if they
spend months on something and it doesn't
work out, and also risky for the firm
that doesn't have a lot of human capital.
And so I've seen companies as big
as Microsoft and smaller companies,
like Foursquare, benefit greatly
by collaborating with academics.
Who generally will, if you allow them to
do research and publish out of the data,
will work for
low wages or no wages, depending on
the agreement you make with them.
And your lawyer sometimes wants
you to pay them something.
But you can sort of put some of your
exploratory analyses out to really,
really smart people.
And it might seem like the application
is a little bit removed from your
core business, but along the way,
they discover really great things.
For those of you in companies that
haven't taken advantage of that,
feel free to email me at Stanford, and
I can tell you a little bit about how
companies have done that successfully.
Let's come back to Lee, and
hear a little bit about your perspective.
>> Sure.
Actually, I just want to add on to.
In terms opening up the data, and
then opening up the platform to
university and collaborate with academia.
I think Baidu has their fair
amount of work, and I think we,
two years ago opened up the data because
obviously we index a large amount of data.
Both webpages and UGCs, and also we
provide a platform, sell the machines
to Chinese universities for students
to experiment and to run MapReduce.
But ultimately, I just want to
add on to provide my perspective.
Ultimately, not to object to your opinion,
but
I don't want my friends to know about
MapReduce just to figure out a restaurant.
I think those information
should be readily available,
should they have ask the right question.
And in terms of the data,
I think when we talk about big data,
talk about the mobile application,
the first to think when it get popular is
to me I know about mobile application.
The first thing is my kids books, and
a children story and kids friendly games.
But it's involving, as we see,
not only games, books,
restaurants, nowadays, there's and
is a popular, online medical consultation.
The travel, you go to an unknown place and
they will tell you what's about this
place, and it's all fascinating.
I think one of the challenges
we have as the research shows,
when you have hundreds of applications on
your mobile phone you really don't know
what to, like you know your question,
you don't know how to search it.
because applications sometimes
has fancy names not really
correlated to their function.
And most of the applications
are long tail.
If you're using WeChat or Weibo every day,
that's fine, you remember where they are.
But if you just call
a cab in New York once,
you just went to a no
place somewhere in China,
you get the application and
it's just a one-time use.
And I think one thing to solve it
is again, the data science come in
August by to announce the light
app initiative basically for
those long tail applications.
We utilize our experience in search and
the data science.
We figure out what's the application and
mobile side that was suitable for
you to use.
And activate it and
you have the option to install or not.
And I think this is just one way
data technology will help your life.
I give example just because
I think in daily life,
you don't just WeChat or
you don't just Facebook.
There is a lot of long-term needs
you don't know what to use.
And the Internet actually have
abundance of resource people developed,
but also, sometimes, I feel so
weird application to fit the niche need.
But nobody knows and
it's sad for the developers.
It's sad for the users and
we need a connection.
And I think certainties for
the connection that we call
the big data sciences connections.
Basically, we need to
connect the needs for
the supplies of these needs and
that's yeah.
>> Excellent, and so Simon has it.
LinkedIn sits on
an amazingly rich data set.
If you think about, for years,
various government organizations or
research organizations spend lots and
lots of money to collect
data about a small sample of individuals
and try to follow their careers over time.
You still can't really
figure out what people do or
what their jobs are from that data.
It's very difficult for
a social scientist to really understand
the career path of an individual.
But LinkedIn now has better data
than any government dataset,
at least ever in the United States.
There's a few northern European countries
who track their people very closely.
But what are the sort of non-obvious or
sort of unexpected applications for
maybe benefiting greater society or
benefiting new products that
come out of what LinkedIn does?
>> That's a great question, and I want to
reflect on what Michael and Leda shared.
So first, talk about the data.
I think on LinkedIn,
actually LinkedIn data is at
a certain level quite simple, right?
A profile like a resume and
then on the back end,
there are a lot of connections, right?
People know people,
people connect with people.
Like [INAUDIBLE] in some of
the basic applications we build.
So inspired by Michael's flowing chart,
right, people flowing in day by day.
I can zoom out and
I can consider the time span from hours or
days into months or years.
Still consider people
movement rightly now.
Think about it, people are moving
across different positions,
companies like in our continents or
industry.
And at the LinkedIn,
by using this profile,
we can easily see
the migration of talents.
So in China, we have a traditional
word that say hey, water flow down,
people move up, right?
Use that very simple concept.
Actually internally,
we create a high-level talent flow.
We found out that people really move up,
right?
Everyone, everyday so and by doing that,
we derive in ourselves a arbors
like I say we run a motion
of insightful or
most popular companies run the work.
So, by having some insight like this,
I believe this can help a lot of
professionals to develop
their career quickly.
So, and that's one use case.
Second use case,
let's help our students, right?
Students, and at the LinkedIn,
let's consider in a professional,
network, right, connections.
So last year actually,
last year, last summer,
a couple interns in my group,
one from, I think, University
of Chicago, and then one from Stanford.
By using the pure only two columns data
who contacted whom within the company?
Actually, we are able to derive a high
level of structure for the company.
The accuracy at a certain
level is phenomenal.
Both interns right now, they are still in
university, they publish patterns, papers.
And by having some information like that,
we believe we can help our
organization significantly.
For example, let's say one company,
one general manager to manage in Yemaya.
We found that those who are social in
our connection within the company.
We can find that person easily resolve it
even thinking about the empty Parliament
title or location because their social
network shows his influence and
the power, right?
Second, by having this
kind of information,
we also can help other companies to
develop more business opportunities,
let's say we start this firm.
Some how you know, sales people
always try to figure out a path,
they promote their own products or
marketers or advertisers.
By having this type of
insightful information,
we can help them accelerate successfully,
very fast.
So, but
these too are done by students, right?
Interns, they still in college and
amazingly, talented people.
And we just cannot thank more for
those kind of people.
>> That's right, so mean partly with so
much untapped potential.
And there's so much low-hanging
fruit that even PhD students or
undergraduates can unlock incredibly
interesting new insights and
personally, I love just
to play with new data.
It's always so much fun.
So we've been talking for the last few
minutes about just the data itself and
the information and
insights that can be unlocked from it.
Let's turn back now to some things that
were touched on, especially by Simon,
about how you actually manage successfully
and organization based on big data.
So let me ask the audience.
How many people work in a firm or
have worked in
a firm that is really
a big data driven company?
So a small set.
I would say that as we go forward,
that's going to become more and
more the norm in the economy as more and
more firms, all the firms
represented here, the data is sort
of completely core to their product.
And so you couldn't conceive of
starting the firm without embracing it.
Yet, we may see more and more firms to
whom at first the big data is sort of
tangential, seeing it become more and
more up front and center.
So let's talk about some insights
from the pioneers, the canaries in
the coal mine of the big data business
management, what the insights are.
I want to start with asking the panelist
to tell us what are the really
core differentiating features
of a data-driven firm?
What's really different
than other organizations?
And I think Simon raised a really
great point that one aspect is that
every employee has access to data and
can get insight quickly.
That's an amazing opportunity, it also.
Is actually asking a whole
lot of your workers
in the sense that maybe your sales force.
And companies like Google and
Microsoft, the sales force has to be
able to work with your databases.
They have to be able to create their own
reports and analyze it intelligently.
That's a much different standard for
sort of Rankin File's marketing
organization than we had in the past.
So I think that's one element,
but I'm going to be starting with
Simon and we'll move back across.
Can you say,
what are the other differentiating
features of a data driven firm.
>> So, I think LinkedIn, actually,
these always start with
saying huge problem you know?
And the challenge was, about a three and
a half years ago I joined Linkedin and
I support only one vertical
business at a moment.
So the first year, personally speaking,
as a data scientist I close
500 different requests.
Building models, visualization,
convincing stats that make decisions,
support in PM marketers and sales people.
So 500 different types of projects,
I was really working around
the clock at that moment.
But at that moment I supported
200 people almost directly,
if you could do the simple math, right?
Every year, every year,
500 divided by 200,
I only answer two major questions
per employee every year.
That's not data driven,
that's not inspiring.
So the problem is the system,
the data set is so complex and slow.
We found out not many people were able to
access those insightful
information to make decisions.
Because they have to wait hours,
days, weeks to get the insights.
How to do that?
I ask all my internal clients quickly,
hey, what do you need?
They say, Simon, very simple,
we need to have the insights very quickly.
I say, how quickly?
They ask, within two seconds.
This is real,
this was [LAUGH] real, two seconds.
I say, two seconds that's impossible,
I never see any system that can
answer questions like that.
They said, who cares,
we only need this within two seconds.
Longer than that, thank you very much,
you don't need to talk to me anymore.
[LAUGH] And so
that's a huge challenge, right?
Before, it was hours, days, weeks,
and then we had to very innovative and
think of a way how to
correct that problem.
Actually, as of today,
we developed a system.
Actually, within three months after
that question had been raised.
The response time, I would say recently,
is maybe a couple of hundred milliseconds.
When people click the button
they get exactly what they need.
It's not what they ask,
it's very different than comparison,
what's been asked and what they need.
Then they can use the insider
to close the arsenal right away.
So after that long we see daily adoptions,
almost 90% employees for that particular
department, which is huge by the way.
So think about that, every week,
every day the are being used.
And we see the hyper leap of revenue
growth, plus better user experience for
LinkedIn members, like all of us.
And I didn't inspire,
I think that's a key.
How to make the incentive for
a lot of people and
then help them to have a better life.
So, yeah.
>> Okay so, let me add on this
flavorful from BIDU experience.
I think a data driven company means
that everything, every result,
every project established, and
also even every critical question asked.
There would be a follow up question
from your peer or your boss,
like what's the data to support it.
Because BIDU has 20,000 people, and
every day there will be
initiatives from the bottom up.
There will be command from the top and up.
When Robin asked me a question, I would
say yes or no before a natural question.
A natural follow-up is what's
the data to support your opinion.
And that's the attitude I think
from top to the bottom that we,
every engineer, every product manager
should hold to and even the sales person.
because when you make a request
because everybody in this company gets
a lot of requests, like Simon said.
And to make it a priority right, to make
the decision right, you need the data.
And I think nothing comes free,
so we really need
the data to see whether it's
fruitful to go down this path.
Obviously some people have
more intuition than others, so
chances are you just need a little bit
of key data to support your opinion.
But still I think that is the key
attitude that you should have.
That, I think, is the most important
factor as a data driven company.
>> Yeah, so actually I really
agree with what Simon said
about making those data
insights happen right away.
I know that one of the most annoying
things I have to do is like write a map
reduce to get an answer.
I write the map reduce,
four hours later it returns an answer,
I've already forgotten why
I cared about the answer.
But I think perhaps a more fundamental
issue really is sort of using data and
having a culture that's driven
by looking at the data.
Actually with your indulgence, I'd like
to make this a little interactive.
A friend of mine actually works
at a teenage call center.
So if you're a young teen you might be
experiencing some psychological issues or
you might be depressed.
You call into the hotline and they'll
have a person who talks you through it.
They say one of two things when you call.
Either, hi I'm a specialist,
how can I help you?
Or, hi I'm a counselor,
And show of hands, I'm curious to know
who in the room thinks that specialist
is better versus counselor?
Everyone has to vote, so raise your
hand if you think counselor is better.
Come on, raise, okay.
Now, and then raise your hand if
you think specialist is better.
Raise your hands, okay.
It looks like it's
a slightly larger group.
So keep your hands up, so people who
said specialist, keep your hands up.
It turns out that you're
actually in very good company.
They had a large meeting of experts on
this area, like experts in childhood
development, and clinical development,
and psychology come together.
They had two day conference and
discussed this very question, and
the experts all came back and said.
We need to use specialists, and
that was like the consensus
amongst these hotlines, for years.
Now okay, everyone who said counselor,
can you raise your hand?
Okay, so it turns out that you're not in
good company, but you're actually right.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Because see,
my friend who works for this hotline,
he's actually a data scientist.
And he just doesn't accept what
people say, he tests it out.
So he gets thousands of calls a day,
he runs it through a AD test, right?
A randomized control trial, and
some people get counselors,
some people get specialists.
It turns out counselor, the rate of
people who don't hang up, who keep on
having a conversation with the person
at the other end went up three-fold.
So huge improvement, what are the morals
I take away from this story?
One, you can't always rely on experts.
We know from the literature,
as I'm sure you're aware,
that people are really bad at
reasoning about statistics and
environments where there's
a lot of randomness.
We're just like biologically
not equipped to do this.
That's why b,
that's why we invented statistics.
And that's why we collect data and
we try to measure this stuff.
But c, and I think this is the big
take away from this whole thing.
The reason why my friend was allowed
to do this is because he worked at
a hotline where the boss
actually believed in data.
And he didn't just listen to what
the conventional wisdom was or
what the experts said.
He actually said lets test this out,
we can test it.
And if the answer doesn't agree what
the expert said, we're changing it.
I think that that kind of data driven
culture has to come from the top.
Has come from what the executives say,
and if you're a leader
you have to hold people in our entire
organization accountable to the data.
And not just we're just going to
do what everyone else is doing, or
what the experts say we should be doing.
>> Excellent.
So let me close out this
part of the discussion and
I'm sure in the interest of time
I'll take the final word on it.
But I'm sure all the panelists
have their own anecdotes.
So one of the things that those of us who
are huge fans of data-driven cultures
love to tell these stories and
champion them.
But we've also seen the pitfalls that can
arise when you become too data driven.
And so just for example,
if you're in a search engine
pretty much every change you make
is going to go to an A/B test.
That is you might get 1% of users who are
going to be exposed to the new algorithm
or the new font or
the new color or the new layout.
And that's going to be
compared to a control group.
And because that data is so strong and
so powerful and so clear and so
black and white, it's really easy
to pay a lot of attention to that.
But then, when you do something new or
different or something that
might have a long-term effect.
It's not necessarily going to show
up even in the right direction
in a short term test.
But long term tests
are much more expensive,
if you're doing an advertiser experiment,
it might be disruptive for advertisers.
It might change their prices or
their click volume and so on.
So you don't do those long
term experiments all the time.
And you have to rely on some intuition and
judgement to know,
when is it worth while to really
put a change to greater scrutiny.
And because you don't always do it,
you can sometimes see an organization
push towards those things,
which create short term results.
But might even be bad, in the long term.
Just as an example,
when Bing launched its re-brand.
The initial response of the users, in the
short term tests, was that they hated it.
They missed their ten blue links,
they didn't understand this new,
more complex interface.
Search engines weren't supposed to have,
richer content,
and more options to navigate the search.
But it took weeks for
the results to come back where the users
after a while really liked it better.
So I can see that as we go forward and
firms become more and
more data-driven, I think you also
expect to see firms sometimes just
drive off a cliff like
sort of little by little.
And then one day they wake up.
The ads in the Facebook feed,
they looked fine.
The users didn't mind them, they didn't
mind them, they didn't mind them.
And then one day they wake up and
they've gone somewhere else.
And that's something that's
a real challenge to balance.
And I know everybody's
nodding their heads.
They all have their own stories.
But rather than hear them, what I want to
do is take the last part of the panel, and
open things up to the audience for
questions.
We have microphones around the room,
please come on up if you have a question.
And please identify yourself and
speak from the microphone.
So it's looks like we have
a question back here.
>> Yeah, my name is Aldus I'm
with Rag Dog Industries.
About 15 to 20 years ago I
remember reading lots of articles,
they almost all mentioned beer and
Huggies.
And I think that was the first time
big data kind of came into the popular
consciousness of the technology people.
And it was kind of a big disaster I
recall, because we did have data but
we didn't know how to ask
the questions to get the answers.
I'm not really sure that I'm
convinced we've learned that yet.
I'd love to hear from the panel
what you guys think we have
figured out in the last ten years
that will make it work this time.
>> I think the classic example you gave,
I have a confidence we
saw that to that extent.
But going beyond that actually there
will be more variables in scale
come out from just
a correlation of two products.
Where why people buy them together.
And I think that, to me,
it will solve the problem, but
this again is just the beginning.
And there's a lot of problems
haven't been solved.
And I believe our technology will lead
to us, it's just haven't been there yet.
>> So just from an educator's perspective,
we've been talking a lot about
how we need to change education.
>From elementary school up through MBAs and
even PhDs in computer science or
PhDs in statistics probably
don't spend enough time.
Thinking conceptually about data
not just what's the algorithm and
how can I improve the algorithm
to come up with a better fit.
But actually, well, can I even
answer this question to start with?
Even if I had a trillion observations,
is the structure of the data such
that I could make a causal statement?
If I changed price what would happen?
And if I changed this
interface what would happen?
Are you seeing more police officers
in areas with higher crime but
clearly increasing police
officers doesn't increase crime.
And that's in some senses,
it's obvious, and everybody knows it.
But actually the expertise of really
understanding in the grey area,
when can you and when can't you
learn something from the data.
It's a very rear skill,
it's something that takes years to master.
And it's something that I believe,
should be part of all disciplines.
Reiterated over and over, and
from different directions,
until people can become experts in it.
>> Yeah.
No I think it totally requires
domain knowledge, and understanding
the thing you are looking at.
I mean,
one of the classic examples of this,
is if you run an image search engine.
If you just followed clicks as a metric
of whether or not the metric was good,
you would just get pictures of scantily
clad women everywhere, no matter what.
Like it doesn't matter if you Google for
Martin Luther King,
it's just scantily clad pictures.
And maybe temporarily it
makes the users happier, but
after a while, they're going to be like,
actually I was here to do some research.
I can't seem to be able to do it now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So they'll go and
use another search engine, right?
So it's really as you say you
can sometimes follow data and
drive yourself off a cliff.
And you have to have that domain
knowledge and understand these things.
>> Yeah, but
I think just want to add on thing.
In fact, every good projects or products
actually start from a good question.
Like Solon just said,
can I think out this?
And actually asking the right
question is the most important step.
And I always feel like coming
from the engineering background,
the confidence, once we know what
the right question is there will be
enough talent to work hard to
get the answer in two seconds.
>> So we have another question
from the audience here.
>> I'm Stephanie.
I'm a student at Stanford
studying computer science, and
I'm a big fan of data.
I was working with Google
maps over the summer,
where data played a really
really important role.
My question is related to your last note
about the pitfalls of being too data
driven.
So I'd love to hear some examples of
when you've kind of made a potentially
dangerous move by prioritizing
short term benefits over long term.
And then what measures you've done
to kind of then counter that?
>> Maybe I can take this question.
To answer this question,
I have two part of answers.
Number one, gentleman's question.
Ask the right question, how can we ask the
right question by using data, two parts.
Mine's a decent partner they ask questions
Another thing I think is very important
for any data professionals.
There's three pillars.
Number one, business sense.
Number two, art.
Number three, science, mathematics.
These three combined together actually
end up with one thing, imagination.
How can we use the existing
such a blank data sheet
to derive unbelievable power and
energy and value?
I think that's why, war breeds a lot
of passion, new ideas and questions.
I think that's what we are doing
right at LinkedIn every day.
To answer another long term
question that you ask,
I think that's back to the vision,
the business strategy.
Pretty simple, at LinkedIn,
we always believe in, member first.
That's why a lot of things we can do by
using data, but we are not doing that,
because we consider members
benefits the first, right?
That's answer to it hasn't
hey if I can short term,
make a lot money free sample,
selling data.
We can make a lot of money, but
that's extremely wrong, right?
It's extremely wrong, and
it would not benefit the company or
the members long-term.
So I think that's back to the bottom line.
What's the basic value we provide for
our LinkedIn members?
And then help them be more successful.
I think if we have that ambition in
our head, always this long term,
short term question,
could be readily answered, easily, so.
Any panelists?
>> Yeah, I mean I'll talk a little
bit about monetization at FourSquare.
So as we've heard,
it's not easy to monetize mobile because
you have this small screen and whatever
you show to a user means you're not
showing some other piece of information.
And one of the things we
can show is an ad but for
example even if Taco Bell
is paying us to show ads.
If you have never been to a fast food
restaurant, if your friends don't
go to Taco Bell if your cellphone you can
quickly go to Mexican restaurants often.
We're not going to show you a Taco Bell
ad because that would just be a bad user
experience.
And we know that maybe
you would click on it and
we could make a little bit of money.
But we understand that long term
that's bad for users and bad for
engagement and especially on such
a small amount of real estate.
We're not going to waste those pixels
showing you something you don't want.
>> So, I think that just sort of
summarize, and it's my observation as well
that to counter that short term
data driven, sort of narrow focus.
You really need a clear vision,
and the leaders of your company
really have to tell the people
what matters in the long term.
So, that that's how they'll be thinking
to balance the short term data.
So we're out of time.
This has been an amazing panel.
And then we'd like to thank
the panelists for all of their insights.
>> Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]